so answer this do you like what trump
did that time in helsinki in the summer
of 2018. if you were advising trump
before he stood with putin in front of
the world would you have told trump to
say that can i ask you a question answer
that one wait a minute for me answer
that one when negotiation happens
what part of the negotiation are you
involved in
i asked you a simple question when
negotiation happens what part of the
negotiation are you going to advise
trump to say that yes or no whatever he
said or he won't answer the article what
happened in helsinki
whatever he said or he didn't say
here's what you need to know why didn't
russia invade ukraine during his term
you're avoiding tell me question why you
guys are yourself
you guys have been getting emotional
no no no you are now we can talk about
ukraine that's a good separate issue
when trump stood in helsinki with putin
do you like what trump did there which
which part of the court do you want to
do you want do all my commentary on pull
up the quote
be specific i'll give you my commentary
on it
president putin says it's not russia i
don't see any reason why it would be
russia president putin says it's not
russia i don't see any reason why it
wouldn't be who's this this is trump
asked if he believed he the quest
question was specific president trump do
you believe your own intelligence
agencies which say russia meddled in the
election or do you believe president
putin who says russia didn't meddle and
these are the same
intelligence agencies that worked
tyler's died overnight to make sure that
he was ousted so they had a backup plan
that comey was against
so what did he say you're upset with the
fact that he says president putin says
it's not russia i don't see any reason
why it would be okay let me stood up let
me tell you what my style would be you
ready here's my style
you ready go ahead unlike being
emotional
you know guys like the two of you
i would say to him behind closed doors
now i got leverage in negotiating with
you you're not behind closed doors my
friend no no
i think you missed the point you missed
the point what i just said
if i sit there and i'm negotiating with
you if i sit there and i negotiate with
you and i say this
you don't deliver on my asks you don't
have my i don't have your back it's a
different game
you can't come and say something like
this and then behind closed doors you're
not you're not giving me what i'm asking
you
you lose leverage with me so what do you
what are you supposed to say here tell
me what you're supposed to say so give
me what you would say your president joe
walsh next to putin give me your words
yes russia meddled in the 2016 election
you're a knight emotional president
that's why you're not a president
okay pat can i oh no let me that's why
you're not a president let me finish
what i would have said because if you
would have said that you could
potentially cause the war now america is
getting get hit by it because you don't
know how to answer questions i would
have i would let me that's the problem
yes because i was asked who do i believe
i would have said yes i believe
america's intelligence community russia
did meddle with it with our election but
you don't know that for a fact okay hold
on yes
don't know that for a fact let me give
you one fact and then you guys can
debate this
and this is not a motion there's no name
calling here
he said quote unquote president putin
says it's not russia i don't see any
reason why it would be quote unquote
what did he do the next day trump let's
talk facts what did trump do the next
day
no no joe i know he went and he said i'm
sorry i misspoke i actually said he was
trying i don't see any reason it
wouldn't be i spoke incorrectly trump
came out and made a statement said i
spoke wrongly fact he went is this a
trump trump responded by tweeting that
he had great confidence
so the next day he 100 percent reversed
questions we're not going to read the
latter half of that tweet as the world's
two largest nuclear powers we must get
along what okay first okay separately
someone came to him and said hey donald
you're in trouble uh you completely
[ __ ] up yeah on the world stage yeah
you're gonna need to go ahead and uh
flip exactly what you said and pretend
people are stupid and said oh i actually
meant i wouldn't be it's the exact same
situation when he said i'm here with uh
tim apple the ceo of uh of apple and he
and he goes it's actually tim cook he's
like dude no i said cook it's like you
said tim apple adam do you realize how
much of a fool you look like right now i
don't because i'm telling the truth do
you do you realize why am i a fool
because i think i told you the exact
story that happened adam
so that's emotions that i'm saying
reading quotes can i
you gonna keep doing this or what do you
want to do
okay not emotional
wait a minute so you guys see this you
guys having some excitement right you
guys getting around this is fantastic
now you're getting garage on the phone i
don't find this let me let me tell you
so now say that yes fast forward to
today your vote america is a [ __ ] show
nobody gives a [ __ ] what you're saying
whether there's any credibility to that
or not america is a laughing stock in
the world today because of your vote
congratulations phenomenal job guys
awesome stuff you should be proud of
yourself
you should be able to brag so i
understand you emotionally have to
defend your vote no i don't you have to
defend yourself i'm not defending my
vote i have to defend you because i
think joe biden's doing it it's not the
point
you're you're thinking he's [ __ ] the
bet but but it's not but things could be
right at the same time adam trump could
be a liar and siding with russia and joe
biden can be a bad president
two things could be correct at the same
time i wanna believe and i'm gonna
believe this about you pat that if you
had trump's ear before he went out on
that stage with putin
you would have told him advised him not
to say what he said i think you would
have you got you guys are living you
guys are living in a but i want to
believe you would have you you guys live
in a uh a universe where unicorns fly
and the never-ending story you know
by the way so
which is great so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]